Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera, buonasera a tutti.
Eccolo qui.
A proposito di bellezza,
questa fotografia l'ho scattata
ieri pomeriggio:
ero in cerca di ispirazione
per il talk di questa sera,
e ho fatto quattro passi vicino casa.
Io abito nelle campagne di Brindisi,
tra i ruderi delle case
della riforma fondiaria
e le vecchie masserie.
In realtà ho fatto
quello che faccio da oltre 30 anni;
quando eravamo bambini,
il nostro divertimento preferito era,
nelle lunghe giornate estive,
prendere la bicicletta
e inoltrarci nei tratturi
delle campagne del nostro paese,
alla ricerca delle vecchie dimore
di campagna abbandonate,
delle torri incustodite,
dei trulli crollati.
Un divertimento che, immagino,
anche qualcuno di voi abbia goduto
nella sua infanzia, nella sua giovinezza.
Non avrei però mai immaginato
che quei luoghi abbandonati,
scenari fantastici
per le storie di noi bambini,
luoghi dell'avventura, dell'esplorazione,
sarebbero diventati nel corso del tempo
il mio mestiere, il mio lavoro.
Io mi chiamo Roberto Covolo
e per professione
rigenero spazi in abbandono;
e provo a farlo
coinvolgendo le comunità locali
in queste trasformazioni.
Penso che sia un lavoro
indispensabile e necessario,
perché oggi in Italia esistono
750.000 immobili pubblici dismessi.
E sono vecchie caserme,
scuole che hanno chiuso
a causa del calo demografico,
mercati che hanno chiuso i battenti,
edifici religiosi, aree industriali.
Pensate che a Brindisi,
la città nella quale vivo,
tre quarti dell'area industriale,
cresciuta in maniera esponenziale
a partire dagli anni 60,
oggi è in condizione di abbandono.
Alcune stime dicono che in Italia esistono
circa 50.000 fabbriche abbandonate;
qualcuno si è messo a spulciare
nei siti delle agenzie immobiliari,
a scala nazionale,
e ha scoperto che ci sono
100.000 capannoni in vendita.
Il Ministero per le Attività
e Beni Culturali,
in una classificazione recente,
ha stimato che su 110.000 beni
del nostro patrimonio di beni culturali,
di patrimonio minore,
circa il 60% è in condizioni
di degrado, di scarso utilizzo,
di inaccessibilità
rispetto alla fruizione.
Questo vuol dire che abbiamo
un grande patrimonio dismesso,
una specie di enorme geografia
dell'abbandono nel nostro paese,
che però non è scevra da contraddizioni.
Pensate che in Italia,
nonostante questa enorme mole,
milioni di metri cubi
di immobili in abbandono,
ogni anno, negli ultimi 50 anni
600.000 ettari di superficie
è stata edificata.
Ogni giorno 33 ettari, 370 m2
per ogni cittadino italiano.
E nonostante questo,
Tenete conto del fatto
che negli ultimi 50 anni,
nello stesso periodo,
la crescita demografica è stata del 26%,
e la crescita edilizia invece del 400%.
Ma nonostante questo,
oggi in Italia abbiamo
sette milioni di case vuote;
oggi, in Italia,
circa 100.000 persone sono senza casa;
oggi in Italia il 25%
delle famiglie, ci dice l'Istat,
vive in condizioni di sovraffollamento
delle proprie abitazioni.
Le nostre città e la nostra esperienza
sono povere di luoghi comuni,
di spazi di fruizione
che siano alternative
a luoghi di mero consumo
o a luoghi di utenza,
pubblici in senso tradizionale.
Dobbiamo interrogarci
su questa geografia dell'abbandono,
sulle contraddizioni che serba,
perché l'abbandono è un grande spreco
dal punto di vista sociale,
dal punto di vista economico,
dal punto di vista ambientale,
dal punto di vista territoriale.
Rispetto a questo spreco,
i grandi player del settore -
penso alle grandi municipalità,
penso a Cassa Depositi e Prestiti,
penso all'Agenzia del Demanio,
mostrano scarsa fantasia.
Succede che sono stretti in una morsa,
tra la cartolarizzazione da un lato,
ovvero il fatto di vendere per fare cassa,
per riequilibrare un bilancio;
o la psicosi della Corte dei Conti,
quella per cui, quando hai
un immobile pubblico,
la prima cosa che ti viene
in mente di fare
è provare a fare cassa
provando a trasformare la tua vocazione
di ente per il bene comune
in una specie di agenzia immobiliare.
E invece noi, in Puglia,
abbiamo provato a costruire
una strada differente in questi anni.
Ho avuto la fortuna
di partecipare, per diversi anni,
a un programma di politiche
pubbliche in questa regione,
che immagino molti di voi conoscano,
che si è chiamato"Bollenti spiriti",
basato su un'idea molto semplice.
Ovvero, che i giovani di questa regione
potevano non essere considerati una specie
di riserva indiana di cui prendersi cura,
un pezzettino delle politiche giovanili
o delle politiche del Welfare,
quelle per cui ti occupi
di questioni giovanili
come se fossero questioni
del disagio e dell'inclusione.
Invece, abbiamo provato a leggere
le politiche per i giovani
con la chiave del progresso
e dello sviluppo di questo territorio,
dicendo che i ragazzi potevano essere
una risorsa da rimettere in circolo,
per generare cortocircuiti positivi
nelle città e nei quartieri,
mettere in contatto le vocazioni
delle giovani generazioni
con i bisogni di sviluppo
della nostra regione.
E dentro questo programma
abbiamo disegnato un'azione
che si chiamava "Laboratori Urbani",
anche questa basata
su un'idea molto semplice.
L'idea per cui agli spazi
servono delle idee
per poter essere rimessi nel circuito
della vita sociale ed economica;
e al tempo stesso,
ai ragazzi servono degli spazi.
E allora siamo andati
in giro per la regione,
chiedendo ai sindaci:
"Ce l'hai il vecchio
mattatoio abbandonato?
Il mercato della frutta dismesso?
Quella scuola che non utilizzate più?
Bene, rinuncia all'ennesima
speculazione edilizia,
a costruire una palazzina.
Ce ne sono tante,
rispetto alle tendenze demografiche
della nostra città!
Basta all'ennesimo centro commerciale
nei nostri centri urbani
e nelle nostre periferie!
Perché non proviamo, insieme,
a costruire un'infrastruttura di luoghi
in cui i ragazzi pugliesi
possano imparare, possano incontrarsi,
scoprire le proprie vocazioni,
approcciarsi al lavoro?"
Questo è stato "Laboratori urbani",
un'operazione abbastanza importante
dal punto di vista dei numeri.
Ha coinvolto oltre 100 mila metri quadri
di spazi pubblici dismessi
nella nostra regione,
oltre 150 immobili,
un investimento
di oltre 50 milioni di euro.
Probabilmente la più importante operazione
di infrastrutturazione materiale
mai fatta da una regione in Europa,
rispetto ai luoghi
per le giovani generazioni.
Oggi, mentre stavo preparando
questa chiacchierata tra noi,
scartabellando nelle fotografie
ho trovato questa fotografia,
che è del 2009,
ed eravamo all'inaugurazione
di questo spazio.
Anche lo spazio che ci ospita oggi
è stato frutto di questa politica;
ed è il motivo per cui mi hanno appioppato
l'incipit della giornata di oggi.
Quel giorno eravamo lì,
c'erano gli amministratori dell'epoca,
c'erano gli artisti, i performer,
i funzionari pubblici,
c'era con noi anche Guglielmo Minervini
al quale vorrei dedicare
il mio intervento di oggi.
(Applausi)
Lui ebbe l'intuizione di dire
che gli spazi abbandonati delle città
potevano essere un'opportunità per tutti,
non semplicemente un'occasione
predatoria per pochi;
spazi per tutti e non,
semplicemente, occasioni per pochi.
Abbiamo portato avanti
questa iniziativa a lungo;
è stata un'operazione complessa
in cui provare a costruire un'alchimia
tra amministrazioni pubbliche,
convincere gli uffici tecnici
che non si trattava esclusivamente
di recuperare un immobile,
ma bisognava mettere insieme
le energie dei ragazzi,
costruire un pubblico
intorno a queste strutture,
favorire uno shift
da una logica di fruizione
dello spazio di clientela
ad una logica di coproduzione,
cioè progettare le maniere
attraverso cui uno spazio è vivo
durante tutte le ore del giorno,
e costruisce un'economia
al proprio interno.
Attraverso questa politica,
sono nati spazi importanti
in questa regione:
un vecchio pattinodromo
abbandonato a Mesagne
è diventato il "Salento Fun Park";
un vecchio mercato dei fiori a Trepuzi
è diventato il "Livello undici ottavi",
un grande spazio per la musica;
a Lecce, una vecchia scuola
per operai metalmeccanici
è diventata "Le Manifatture Knos".
Come dire: è stata un'operazione
che ancora oggi, se ci troviamo
in questo posto,
vuol dire che ha seguito
un'intuizione giusta.
Che cosa abbiamo capito
da questa operazione?
Abbiamo capito
che la rigenerazione urbana,
cioè il recupero dell'abbandono,
non è solo un tema di pietre,
non è solo un tema di progetti tecnici,
non è solo un tema di finanziamenti.
Le risorse, e le  infrastrutture,
non sono sufficienti
se manca un'anima, se manca una comunità,
se manca il disegno
dei dispositivi sociali ed economici
che tengono il portone
di questo spazio aperto.
Allora, per approfondire questa ricerca,
mi sono trasferito in un paese
che si chiama San Vito dei Normanni.
È un paese in provincia di Brindisi
in cui c'era questo spazio abbandonato,
un ex stabilimento enologico,
4000 metri quadri, un ettaro di giardino,
uno spazio molto grande,
abbandonato dalla fine
degli anni Cinquanta,
quando le congiunture economiche
dismisero la funzione produttiva
di questo stabilimento.
Per molti anni è stato utilizzato
dalla Pubblica Amministrazione,
che era entrata
in possesso della proprietà,
come ricovero per i mezzi
della nettezza urbana,
come discarica per inerti.
Sapete: i classici vuoti urbani,
i non luoghi che si accumulano
nelle periferie dei nostri paesi
e delle nostre città,
nel corso dell'urbanizzazione,
dell'espansione.
Lì abbiamo avuto questa intuizione,
cioè che recuperare questo spazio
non avrebbe significato solamente
avere un buon progetto tecnico,
avere un buon gruppo
di architetti e ingegneri,
trovare le forme tecniche
e amministrative per poterlo recuperare.
Il tema era lavorare sulla costruzione
di una comunità di organizzazioni attive,
tra loro interconnesse,
che potessero costruire
la gestione dell'ex Fadda.
È stata un'esperienza esaltante,
nel corso di questi anni,
in cui abbiamo provato,
mentre autorecuperavamo lo stabilimento,
utilizzando l'autocostruzione,
coinvolgendo le imprese locali
nei processi di trasformazione,
al tempo stesso lavoravamo con i ragazzi
per creare occasioni
di apprendimento e di lavoro,
favorendo l'associazionismo, la creazione
di imprese sociali, di cooperative
che potessero gestire
i servizi di questo spazio
e produrre nuovi progetti
culturali e sociali.
Recuperando le vecchie stalle
abbiamo dato vita a X-Food,
che è stato il primo
ristorante sociale in Puglia
in cui ragazze e ragazzi con disabilità
hanno imparato un mestiere
e lo hanno messo in pratica,
tra i fornelli in cucina
e tra i tavoli in sala.
Recuperando la vecchia casa del custode
abbiamo creato il bar
di questo stabilimento
in cui lavorano le ragazze madri
che vengono da biografie difficili.
Abbiamo provato a mettere insieme
il recupero delle campate
dello stabilimento
con l'idea che potessero costruirsi
organizzazioni culturali
che incrociavano
le vocazioni del territorio,
legate alla musica,
all'artigianato, allo sport.
Abbiamo fatto una valutazione di impatto,
e oltre 100 persone
hanno avuto occasioni di lavoro
in otto anni di sviluppo
di questa esperienza,
che è un'esperienza che va avanti
nella forma dell'impresa sociale.
Il che vuol dire che, laddove
il mercato non ha interesse,
e laddove lo stato non ha strumenti,
le leve dell'economia sociale
e le leve dell'economia civile,
che è quella economia
che prova a utilizzare
le leve tradizionali del mercato,
non per generare profitto per pochi
ma per aumentare l'impatto sociale
e trasformare le città,
è un'ipotesi che dobbiamo prendere
in considerazione
quando consideriamo il patrimonio pubblico
un pezzo non della speculazione,
non solo dell'urbanistica,
ma un pezzo del Welfare,
un pezzo dell'economia culturale,
un pezzo dell'economia sociale.
La cosa interessante
è stata che questa esperienza
ha ispirato le politiche pubbliche
a livello locale.
E insieme al Comune - perché vedete,
molto spesso nelle politiche pubbliche,
a livello locale, c'è un "vulnus".
Magari gli enti sovraordinari programmano;
ma poi, quando arrivi nei Comuni,
c'è un problema di risorse,
di risorse umane, di tenuta degli uffici,
di capacità di seguire i processi
politici, tecnici, amministrativi,
di qualità della classe dirigente,
soprattutto nei posti dove
il capitale umano è più debole.
La storia del nostro Mezzogiorno.
E allora cosa abbiamo fatto?
Insieme al Comune abbiamo detto
"Proviamo a prendere questa pratica,
nata nella comunità,
e a trasformarla
in una politica pubblica".
Abbiamo scritto un programma
di rigenerazione urbana,
che si chiama:
"Da spazi a luoghi - Santu Vitu mia",
che è un modo di dire
che si usa a San Vito,
una specie di imprecazione.
Abbiamo provato a dire
che il patrimonio pubblico della città
può diventare una leva di welfare
e che possiamo immaginare,
mentre lavoriamo sulle pietre,
sugli edifici, su porzioni di quartieri,
che dobbiamo costruire occasioni
affinché i cittadini,
soprattutto i giovani, imparino -
quindi apprendimento,
apprendimento in situazione -
sperimentino, creino occasione di lavoro
per provare a creare un merge
tra uno spazio che si recupera
e occasioni per la città.
Abbiamo provato a portare avanti
questa esperienza
anche in un lavoro che ho fatto,
in questi anni, da amministratore.
Sono stato Assessore alla
Programmazione Economica e Patrimonio
nella città di Brindisi,
provando a costruire politiche pubbliche
che avessero al centro il tema
del riuso, dell'abbandono,
della valorizzazione del patrimonio.
Allora abbiamo preso un palazzo chiuso
nel centro storico della città,
Palazzo Guerrieri,
e abbiamo provato a trasformarlo
in un laboratorio di innovazione urbana,
cioè un luogo in cui provare
a mettere in contatto
le vocazioni di sviluppo
di una città in transizione,
che sta affrontando la fine
della stagione industriale
e la crisi della sua economia
e del suo tessuto sociale,
con le idee dei ragazzi,
creando un luogo fisico
che potesse diventare
il quartier generale di questa esperienza.
Le nostre città sono così povere
di spazi alternativi
a spazi di mero consumo,
o a spazi di utenza;
Invece, creare spazi di coproduzione,
in cui la città possa
essere costruita insieme,
tra amministratori,
imprese sociali e cittadini
io penso che sia
una funzione indispensabile,
per un'amministrazione contemporanea.
Accanto a Palazzo Guerrieri
abbiamo costruito dei programmi;
uno si chiama"Riusa Brindisi"
in cui abbiamo provato a sfidare
la burocrazia comunale,
che ci poneva il tema
della Corte dei Conti,
della valorizzazione
in termini immobiliari del patrimonio,
e abbiamo detto: "Proviamo
a costruire dei sistemi
attraverso cui compensare servizi
che le organizzazioni sociali
che gestiscono questi spazi
erogano alla cittadinanza
rispetto al valore immobiliare
di questi immobili".
Ci vuole innovazione amministrativa
per rigenerare il patrimonio,
ci vogliono nuove idee e innovazioni.
Dico sempre che l'innovazione
non è il computer negli uffici,
è un nuovo modo di pensare.
L'abbiamo fatto anche sui parchi;
la città di Brindisi dispone
di un patrimonio importante di parchi
molto spesso in condizioni
di sottoutilizzo e di degrado,
perché le risorse pubbliche
sono sempre scarse
rispetto alle necessità di gestione
e di manutenzione del patrimonio.
Allora che abbiamo fatto?
Abbiamo costruito un regolamento
per i beni comuni,
individuiamo i parchi come beni comuni,
chiediamo ai cittadini di organizzarsi
per costruire forme condivise di gestione.
Abbiamo favorito la nascita
di associazioni di quartiere,
di cooperative di comunità
che potessero ragionare sul patrimonio
come leva per un Welfare comunitario.
Questa è la chiave:
costruire un'alleanza nuova
intorno al patrimonio,
per poter promuovere la rigenerazione.
Da tre anni a questa parte,
abbiamo portato la nostra ricerca
su altri fronti, perché -
Va avanti da sola,
però ormai avete capito.
Guardate le foto.
C'è un tema che riguarda la nostra regione
e che riguarda tutto il Mezzogiorno,
e questo tema riguarda un altro aspetto
dell'abbandono e del patrimonio dismesso:
è quello legato ai terreni,
pubblici e privati.
Si stima che in Italia, in questo momento,
ci siano 3,5 milioni
di terreni agricoli inattivi.
A questo tema si associa un tema
di carattere globale, generale -
di agenda, come si dice.
E cioè che, in Puglia,
il 60% della superficie
agricola utilizzabile
è a rischio desertificazione.
Questo è il combinato disposto
di cambiamenti climatici,
pratiche agricole intensive, monocoltura,
perdita di biodiversità, chimica.
Allora cosa sta succedendo?
Che per motivazioni economiche,
demografiche e ambientali,
la terra viene abbandonata;
vengono abbandonate le terre private
e le terre pubbliche.
Voi sapete che in Puglia,
in questo momento
c'è una crisi del nostro paesaggio agrario
decisiva, fondamentale.
Stiamo, come dire, sul crinale
tra un prima e un dopo.
Tra dieci anni, il paesaggio
che noi conosciamo,
il paesaggio degli ulivi
che caratterizza questa regione,
sarà un ricordo del passato.
Questo non dipende semplicemente
dal fatto che arriva un batterio,
ma dipende dalla maniera
in cui ci rapportiamo
rispetto al nostro ecosistema,
dipende dalla gestione del suolo,
dipende dalla struttura
socio-demografica di un territorio,
dipende dalla perdita di biodiversità,
dipende dalla monocoltura.
Allora abbiamo deciso di portare
il nostro metodo di lavoro,
legato all'abbandono,
al tema della rigenerazione
dei terreni abbandonati.
Abbiamo preso in gestione 50 ettari
di terreni confiscati alla mafia
a San Vito dei Normanni:
un deserto sociale ed ecologico,
una ex lavatrice di denaro sporco,
dove c'era il caporalato,
con pratiche agricole super intensive.
Quando abbiamo fatto
le prime indagini sul suolo
all'inizio dell'esperienza,
abbiamo rilevato livelli
di vitalità molto bassa,
assenza totale di biodiversità,
in questa monocultura
che serviva a riciclare denaro,
a produrre reddito per il confiscato.
Ci siamo messi in testa
di creare un'azienda agricola manifesto
che potesse essere, per il territorio,
di ispirazione rispetto al tema
di una nuova economia rigenerativa
basata sul recupero
dei terreni abbandonati,
sulle migliaia di ettari
di terreni abbandonati
che esistono nelle nostre provincie,
soprattutto nella parte meridionale
della nostra regione.
Questo progetto si chiama "X-farm"
e anche in questo caso
ci siamo dati da fare,
per cominciare a fare in modo
che la comunità partecipasse
alla trasformazione.
X-farm è una cooperativa multiculturale
perché nel settore dell'agricoltura
dobbiamo trasformare
il punto di debolezza,
legato alla sopraffazione
dell'uomo sull'uomo,
in un punto di forza,
mettendo insieme i lavoratori,
i giovani, da dovunque vengano.
È un'azienda ecologica
perché non punta semplicemente
a diminuire l'impatto della produzione;
ma punta a rigenerare gli asset naturali
attraverso il recupero dei terreni.
È un'azienda sociale,
perché promuove inserimento lavorativo
per le fasce deboli della popolazione.
È il nostro nuovo esperimento,
su cui spero di potervi
venire a raccontare
degli esiti positivi nei prossimi anni;
magari raccontarvi una bella festa,
perché occorre anche divertirsi
quando si recupera il patrimonio.
Quindi, torno ad una delle foto
che ho scattato ieri pomeriggio,
a proposito di bellezza.
Adesso lo sapete:
quando tornate a casa
chiedete ai vostri sindaci
l'elenco degli immobili abbandonati,
organizzatevi con i cittadini
nel vostro quartiere
per portare avanti un'ipotesi
di riutilizzo di uno spazio pubblico,
per provare a generare
un'azione collettiva.
I tempi che stiamo vivendo
sono i tempi dell'isolamento;
ma l'azione collettiva
è una buona risposta all'abbandono.
Grazie a tutti e buona serata.
(Applausi)